[Musique]
bonsoir je suis romancier est souvent
les lecteurs qui viennent me voir un
salon du livre me pose la question
suivante si vous deviez nous donner un
seul bon conseil pour écrire un livre
lequel serait-il alors je leur réponds
trouver une bonne idée si vous trouvez
une bonne idée c'est déjà un grand pas
dans l'écriture
alors ce soir je vais vous inviter à
entrer dans la tête d'un romancier on va
les découvrir ensemble un peu ce qui se
passe dans cerveau perturbé et j'essaie
de vous montrer comment une bonne idée
peut se concrétiser en une réalité dans
le cadre d'une recherche sur l'idée on a
demandé à un groupe de personnes ou
quand ils trouvaient leurs bonnes idées
et voici les réponses les plus
fréquemment cités le matin en me
réveillant dans les transports en commun
en conduisant sous la douche en faisant
mon jogging et même dans ce lieu très
spirituel que sont les toilettes alors
il ya un point commun à toutes ces
réponses
c'est que la plupart du temps nous
trouvons nos idées au moment où si on
s'y attend le moins
ou quand on ne cherche plus je vous
donne quelques exemples
paul dirac qui était l'un des pères de
la mécanique quantique a trouvé sa
grande idée sur les particules en se
remémorant une maison d'enfance henri
poincaré célèbre mathématicien a réussi
à résoudre un problème sur lequel et
s'acharner depuis des mois en se
promenant bord de la plage on connaît
tous newton qui se reposait
tranquillement sous un pommier
quand il a découvert la gravité alors
j'ai moi même vécu aussi ce genre
d'expérience assez stupide stupéfiante
d'illuminations c'était il ya quelques
années je voulais écrire un roman qui
avait pour sujet de l'évolution
lorsque c'est un thème qui me fascinait
mais je n'arrivais pas en tant que
romancier à exprimer ce qu est l
évolution
j'avais évidemment des explications
scientifiques mais c'était beaucoup trop
complexes passés visuel
et puis un jour un peu comme tous les
autres je vais faire mon petit footing
et je me fais dépasser par un autre
joker qui avait à peu près la même
physionomie que moi et je me souviens
m'être dit mais pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
courent plus vite que moi
et au moment où je le vois disparaître
au loin j'ai eu mon idée qui est apparu
alors je me suis précipité à mon
ordinateur et j'ai essayé de la
schématiser de la façon suivante j'ai
imaginé deux petits dinosaures qui était
poursuivi par un dinosaure bien plus
gros et bien plus agressif et j'étais ce
deuxième petit dinosaure à la traîne
derrière et je dire mon prédécesseur
mais à quoi ça sert de courir puisque de
toute façon il court beaucoup plus vite
que nous et vous savez ce que répond le
prédécesseur il lui dit je ne cherche
pas à courir plus vite que lui cherche
juste à courir plus vite que toi c'était
une idée toute simple mais qui
représentait exactement
finalement l'idée que je voulais me
faire de l'évolution c'est que
l'évolution est une course perpétuelle à
la survie et cette phrase cette idée
allez m'accompagner tout au long de mon
travail d'écriture un peu comme un
mantra que j'allais me répéter chaque
jour allait être le moteur de mes
personnages qu'ils soient policiers
assassins bon méchant tous mes
personnages allaient courir pour leur
survie c'est de cette manière là que je
les ai construit alors est ce que ça
veut dire qu'il faut courir à longueur
de journée au prendre des douches en
permanente pour pour avoir ses idées ses
bonnes idées
certainement pas il suffit de j'ai pris
ces quelques exemples assez
caractéristique emile zola lorsqu'il a
écrit germinal albert einstein avec la
théorie de la relativité ou joseph swan
quand il a inventé l'ampoulé on se doute
bien que ces grandes idées ses bonnes
idées ne sont pas venus en un claquement
de doigt ou au petit bonheur la chance
finalement quel que soit le contexte
quelle que soit l'époque quel que soit
le sujet les bonnes idées met du temps à
germer et sont difficiles à aller
chercher et j'essaye de vous expliquer
pourquoi de manière la plus simple
possible
demandé d'imaginer ses neuf points comme
étant le sujet vous avez envie de
traiter votre matières premières le
terreau dans lequel vous avez envie de
creuser ça peut être un problème que
vous avez envie de résoudre un fait de
société auquel autour duquel vous avez
envie de développer quelques réflexions
ça peut être une envie aussi imaginez
vous aimez la cuisine
vous avez envie de développer vos
propres idées de recettes vous allez
vous entouré de livres d'ingrédients
voilà c'est un peu ce que représentent
ces neuf points puis vous allez vous
mettre à réfléchir pour trouver des
idées et vous allez vous rendre compte
que des idées vont arriver extrêmement
vite très très vite vous allez avoir des
idées mais malheureusement ces idées qui
vont arriver je les met à la poubelle
pourquoi parce qu'elles sont venues trop
rapidement justement la plupart du temps
ce sont des mauvaises idées des idées
déjà existante des clichés des
stéréotypes
elles feront preuve ces idées font
preuve d'un manque de d'inspiration d'un
manque d'originalité
elles font toutes partie ses idées de ce
que j'appelle le champ de réflexion
classique ou la zone de confort on est
tranquillement installé
elle est symbolisée cette zone par ce
cercle qui emprisonne ses idées qui se
contentent d'en tourre est en fait votre
matières premières si je vous demande de
relier ces neuf points en quatre coups
de crayon sans jamais lever votre mine
en quatre lignes dans quatre lignes vous
pouvez essayer mentalement joindre ses
neuf fois en quatre lignes je fais un
essai ici et puis refaire tout un tas d
ces procès de route de rejoindre ces
points on se rend compte finalement qu'à
chaque fois bien on n'y arrive pas par
contre une fois que vous avez éliminé
toutes ses possibilités
et vous allez cherchez vous élargissez
un peu votre zone de réflexion ce que
j'appelle nous sommes des forts il est
très peu probable que votre bonne idée
vous la trouviez dans cette zone
d'efforts j'ai écrit seize romans on à
peu près autant d'années le temps passé
extrêmement vite et je me suis rendu
compte de d'une constante vraiment
surprenante
c'est que je m'étais systématiquement
entre trois et six mois entre le moment
où je terminais mon roman précédent et
le moment je trouvais la bonne idée de
mon roman suivant non pas une semaine
n'ont pas 15 jours et entre trois et six
mois c'est long quand on cherche une
idée je vous laisse imaginer alors
j'essayais de comprendre comprendre
pourquoi ça mettait autant et finalement
la conclusion et c'est assez simple
c'est que trouver une bonne idée demande
du temps des efforts du travail et
beaucoup de passion et ce long processus
je les décomposer en deux deux grandes
étapes qu'on peut appliquer chacun
d'entre nous quand on cherche des idées
la première c'est un peu ce qu'on a fait
pour les neuf points on va éliminer tout
ce qui est mauvais toutes les mauvaises
toutes les mauvaises idées toutes les
idées qui viennent très rapidement on va
les mettre à la poubelle on va vider
notre zone de confort et de toute façon
il faut vous dire que la bonne idée elle
peut pas se trouver là là dedans dans
cette zone de confort parce que
quelqu'un d'autre l'aurait déjà trouvé à
voir vous sinon et puis on va les
nourrir cette zone d'efforts on va lui
donner à manger
alors comment comment on nourrit une
zone d'effort ou à le nourrir par des
rencontres par des réflexions par des
lectures par de la documentation autour
de ce sujet qui vous intéresse qui vous
passionne j'en reviens à mon roman sur
l'évolution jeu j'ai essayé de ne savait
pas à l'époque ce que j'allais écrire
j'avais cette phrase évidemment que
j'avais trouvé avec les dinosaures mais
ça ne me donnait pas l'idée de mon roman
alors je savais je ne savais pas ce que
j'allais écrire mais je savais ce que je
ne voulais pas écrire je voulais pas
écrire des histoires qui existait déjà
que j'avais déjà lu je voulais vraiment
faire différent
donc j'ai rapidement vidé cette zone de
confort et je suis aller nourrir ma zone
d'efforts et comment je les nourris
cette zone de 2 d'efforts par des
lectures toutes ces lectures autour de
l'évolution
j'ai lu tous ses livres il ya là dedans
des thèses des essais des romans même il
ya l'origine des espèces de darwin et
puis je fallait rencontrer des gens des
chercheurs des biologistes des
spécialistes en biologie évolutive
les généticiens pour discuter avec eux
puis je suis allé aussi me promener dans
des lieux qui m'inspiraient là on voit
la grande galerie de l'évolution à paris
mais ce qui est terrible aussi ce qui
est terriblement frustrant c'est que ça
ne vous donne pas la solution pour avoir
la bonne idée ça vous nourrit mais
l'idée j'étais toujours en train de la
chercher à ce moment là qu'est ce que
j'allais écrire malgré toute cette
matière que j'avais accumulé
et puis vient le moment où vous
angoissez tellement que vous avez envie
de passer à autre chose
vous ne pouvez plus est en fait c'est
exactement ce qu'il faut faire passer à
autre chose
j'irai même si une condition essentielle
pour trouver une bonne idée pourquoi
parce que parce que votre cerveau il est
extraordinaire il est capable de
réaliser plusieurs tâches en même temps
et pendant que vous êtes en train de
faire complètement autre chose
il est capable de prendre une tâche est
de la mettre en arrière plan et de
travailler dessus sans vous en
aperceviez vous êtes en train d'envoyer
un email
c'est en train d'assister à une réunion
de courir êtes ici et pendant ce temps
là et à votre idée tout petit un embryon
d'idées qui est en train de la cub et
bien au chaud dans votre cerveau et elle
va se nourrir de toute cette matière que
que vous avez accumulé
elle va même créer des liens entre tous
ces éléments elle va grandir grandir
grandir un moment donné elle va
apparaître dans votre tête un peu comme
par magie par illumination
on voit bien finalement que bien peu de
magie la 2 en mai
si beaucoup de travail et d'efforts en
amont et pour illustrer un peu c'est
tout ce que je vais vous raconter
j'aimerais vraiment vous raconter la
plus grande la plus grande phase ii le
plus grand cycle de recherche incubation
élimination que j'ai pu vivre en
essayant de créer un livret c'était tout
d'ailleurs tout au tout début de ma
carrière d'écrivain pour un roman qui
s'appelle la chambre des morts je
commençais à écrire et à l'époque mon
contrat mais neuf points - est
extrêmement simple
je voulais écrire un roman policier avec
du suspense à l'intérieur voilà bon
assez sympa priori et puis j'avais un
talent vie pour ce livre je voulais que
ça se passe dans la région parce que
c'est la mienne et je l'aimais que
j'avais envie d'en parler dans un roman
mais de manière différente donc je me
suis mis à faire des recherches sur la
région sur sur ces gens sur son histoire
son tissu social
et puis j'ai fait des recherches sur
l'univers policier comment se déroule
une enquête
on se déroule une autopsie je regardais
beaucoup de reportages sur la police
scientifique sur les faits divers procès
de nourrir un peu mon esprit et puis à
l'époque j'étais fasciné par l'effet
papillon je suis toujours d'ailleurs
c'est cette capacité qu'un événement de
modifier tout un tas de destin comme on
dit et dans le roman policier je voulais
aussi qui est un peu de social à
l'intérieur parce que le roman policier
aime bien parler de la société et puis
il fallait évidemment qu'une enquête
policière
c'est important et un grand méchant
parce qu'il y en a toujours en les
romans policiers
et puis un tas d'autres petites envies
comme ça et ça c'était l'état de mon
cerveau à un moment donné et je peux
vous dire je dormais assez mal avec
toute cette matière dans ma tête parce
que je ne savez toujours pas quoi en
faire de sa toujours pas d'idée de
romans ben oui qu'est ce que je vais
écrire avec tout ça toute cette matière
j'avais accumulé
et puis un soir comme tous les autres je
quitte mon travail j'étais ingénieur en
informatique
et je travaillais dans la zone
industrielle de dunkerque où la
reconnaissez et puis je prends ma
voiture et je me retrouve dans cette rue
c'était la nuit y avait toutes ses
lumières il y avait personne dans la
zone industrielle et la scène que je
veux que je vois que je visualise jeu la
visualise encore ce soir
comme je vous vois où j'essaye de vous
voilà en tout cas comme je vous vois
vous je suis en train de rouler et d'un
seul coup
j'imagine je vois une voiture qui
arrivait en face de moi dans cette
voiture il ya deux hommes qui conduisent
extrêmement vite et qui vont percuté un
homme qui traverse à pied à ce moment là
cet homme porte un gros sac d'argent
dans sa main cet argent c'était une
rançon qui est d'ailleurs qu'il allait
remettre un kidnappeur qui était caché
jusque dans un entrepôt juste le long de
cette route et qui n'a peur qui
évidemment a tout vu cette idée elle
m'est venu quasiment instantanément ce
soir là en deux trois minutes
c'est à dire que sans que je m'en rende
compte tous les éléments sur lesquels
j'allais travailler c'était
interconnecter les uns aux autres mon
effet papillon était là c'était
l'accident
l'accident agit toujours sur beaucoup de
destin mais deux hommes qui étaient dans
la voiture allait embarquer le corps et
l'argent ce qu'elle ait généré une
enquête policière
ça se passait dans la région c'était
dans les années une stricte de dunkerque
dont il y avait aussi tout ce tissu
social qui était sous jacent est
évidemment il y avait ce grand méchant
qui avait tout vu et qui se retrouvait
avec une petite fille sous les bras et
sans l'argent et cette idée elle m'a
vraiment explosé en pleine figure quand
je l'aï vu c'était une élimination et à
ce moment là vous savez que c'est la
bonne idée est un écrivain qui a une
bonne idée comme ça mais il n'a plus
qu'une envie c'est de la cde l'écrire
cette idée et cette idée elle va
produire un livre alors et encore du
travail évidemment entre le moment où
vous avez une idée comme celle là elle
est le livre final beaucoup d'eux de
temps passé dessus heures de réflexion
mais on voit bien l'importance de la
bonne idée finalement parce que quand
vous avez une bonne idée
vous tenez déjà votre projet vous tenez
votre livre quand j'ai eu cette idée je
savais que j'avais mon livre était
presque écrit
et puis ce qui est assez génial
finalement dans ce processus de
recherche d'idc que cette bonne idée qui
a été générée après beaucoup de temps et
de travail
vous pouvez vous en servir un peu comme
la brique de base d'un nouveau cycle de
réflexion
c'est dire qu'à un moment donné dans mon
parcours je me suis retrouvé avec tous
ces livres que j'avais écrit les uns
après les autres et tout ça a été un peu
dans ma tête
indépendant et puis comme la première
fois les liens se sont créés c'est un
cube et ça a grandi en moi et puis ça
donnait une autre bonne idée je trouve
qui a été celle de changer de métier en
2007 je suis passé du même de mon métier
d'ingénieur au métier de l'écrivain à
temps plein donc on voit bien que les
bonnes idées peuvent changer le monde
les bonnes idées peuvent rendre le monde
meilleur des petites idées qui
grandissent et qui grandissent et qu'il
grandisse encore et nous pousse vers le
haut et trace les chemins de nos vies
alors je dirais que dans les période de
doute que vous pouvez avoir et on en a
tous et c'est normal je dirais croyez en
vous même croyait en ses capacités
extraordinaires de votre cerveau de
votre esprit et n'hésitez surtout pas à
concrétiser vos idées pour réaliser vos
rêves
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]